I'm very happy to be here thanks for
welcoming me as I said we have a very
strong relationship personal
relationship we met a few years ago
I mean vistas and Doha I did and yes the
relationship between secondary is a very
strong relationship and working forward
for this meeting Nadine barber has more
now from London well ahead of the brief
meeting Prime Minister Johnson did say
that relations between the UK and Qatar
were going from strength to strength
now before the the Emir actually
traveled to London
the UK's ambassador to Qatar made a
statement outlining some of the areas in
which relations were extremely strong he
mentioned trade annually it's worth
around 8 billion US dollars he also
talked about energy he said that Qatar
provides between 20 and 30 percent of
the UK's gas imports and talked of the
UK's wish to help Qatar expand its
liquefied natural gas sector he also
talked about defense cooperation
mentioning that Qatar has aborts or
ordered 24 typhoon fighter jets from
Britain he said that the previous Prime
Minister Theresa May had signed a
commitment to cooperating with Qatar on
areas including health education and
financial services and he said that he
wanted to see all of those areas of
cooperation increased in the coming
years of course the Prime Minister and
the Emir of Qatar will have touched upon
tensions in the Middle East as well but
there's a lot of business interests that
they'll want to have talked about as
well